[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
june is now here and throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
the movie talking about what happens
next and also giving our thoughts on it
as a whole probably gonna get some heat
for my review but we'll get into it and
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here if you enjoy the breakdown then
please hit the thumbs up button and
don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this each and every day without the
way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into tune
okay so something that was kept from
most of the marketing is that june is
actually part one the movie isn't a
self-contained story and danny villanov
has stated in interviews that he's taken
the first book and broke it up into two
parts because of this the film very much
ends at the mid point of the initial
story but due to its closeness to the
source material we can pretty much guess
what's going to happen next now in this
video i kind of want to go through the
plot and explain it with bits from the
book as i know a lot of people are lost
on the inner workings but if you want to
skip ahead to what happens next then
time codes will be linked below now even
before the studio logos come in the
movie starts with a caption that says
dreams are messages from the deep this
is a paramount thing throughout the film
and we slowly watch as a prophecy
foretold in dreams starts to unfold in
this movie we pick up on the desert
planet arrakis and learn of spice the
fremen and evil house hawking from a
local air named chani
played by zendaya she narrates how the
planet has been harvested for its rare
and valuable minerals by the house and
her people were oppressed because of
this this was decreed by an overseer
known as the emperor who eventually
withdrew the harkenings from the planet
and in their place he put the house of
atreides which is pretty much the family
that we follow in the movie the emperor
very much sees the atreides as a future
threat and thus he sends them to the
planet to make sure that they're snuffed
out before they can rise up against him
initially many members of the hakonen
see this as an act against them but as
their leader baron vladimir explains
it's not an act of love the emperor
conspires with the harkenings to bring
roon to the house and the baron becomes
the main antagonist in this first film
now channing asks in the opening who the
next oppressors will be but the atreides
or what's left of them ends up joining
with the fremen at the end of the movie
this somewhat makes the emperor's fear
become a self-fulfilling prophecy but
we'll talk about that later on in the
video now firstly i want to talk about
spice and why it's so valuable it's the
most priceless and elusive substance in
the universe and not only does it
provide interstellar travel for the
imperium but it also prolongs people's
lifespans spice is difficult to get
because giant sand worms patrol the
planet and they attack anything that
makes too much noise including the
production vehicles because of this
arrakis is highly contested and it's not
long after the atreides settle in that
they're attacked by the hawkenans on
several fronts now it's through all this
that we're introduced to our protagonist
paul who is very much prophesized to be
the next space messiah paul dreams of
cheney and several things from the
future that eventually end up coming to
fruition and this is because he was
trained by his mother in the ways of the
beni jesserit they're basically a group
of all female jedis that have the
ability to mind control people and paul
has been brought up with our abilities
since he was a child his mother jessica
was instructed by the religion to only
bear a daughter due to their super
selective breeding program but she went
against this and trained anakin sorry
paul in the ways of the force now
straight up if you're watching this
without really knowing the history of
the book then you might think that it's
ripped a lot of things from star wars
there's of course a desert planet a
chosen one an emperor mystical magic and
spice which is also called spice when
it's in star wars however the june bug
was released way before c-3po ever said
he had a really bad feeling about this
copyright claim and this was very much
used as a blueprint for what lucas would
go on to do george lucas did admit that
star wars was heavily inspired by the
novel and they're both sort of like
poetry that they're very similar
sounding when you when you talk about
them now early on in the movie we see
paul partaking in the gomja bar which is
something that basically tests a
person's humanity the idea behind this
is that the box puts someone through
sheer agony and if they're animalistic
they'll yank their hand away purely on
instinct a human however will have the
ability to think beyond it and hold
their hand in place to continue the test
what you might miss is that paul is
subjected to more pain than anyone ever
has been before and the reverend mother
is testing to see whether he's the
chosen one throughout the book we learn
that paul was actually part of a
secretive eugenics program that the
benny had carried out for millennia in
the hopes of creating a superhuman this
is known as the quizets had a rach and
this is someone whose mind can bridge
the past and future and basically bring
everyone into a higher form of living
which is of course hinted at in paul's
dreams also going to be completely
honest here my pronunciation in this
video is gonna be absolutely terrible
i've heard these names a thousand times
before but i promise you i'll still mess
them up same way that i've heard
scarlett johansson about two thousand
times and i'm still like is it scarlett
johansson or is it johansson i really
don't know and that's why i just call
her scorjo but i can't do that here now
in the movie the baron launches several
attacks on the atreides and these
escalate over time the first is through
a poisonous hunter killer drone and the
follow-up is through a mole known as dr
wellington ua we learned that his wife
was being held by the baron and he not
only disables the shield surrounding the
atreides base but he also offers a pause
for the letto in the hopes of having her
freed is it jared leto or is it jared
leto never mind now during this the
harkenings attack the base and they
completely destroy the fortitude and
wipe out most of the soldiers there paul
and jessica are captured and they're
flown out into the desert where they'll
be left to die now in the film the
mother gaius goes to the baron and
instructs him not to harm the pair and
in doing this he is somewhat keeping his
deal paul and jessica only managed to
escape because they jedi mind trick the
soldiers that capture them and they're
very much forced to face the harshness
of the desert on their own back at the
base ua gives leto a fake tooth that
releases a poisonous gas when someone
bites down on it and he tells him that
he can kill the baroness his final act
if he times it right the baron arrives
tells ua he'll reunite him with his wife
and kills him which is the old you know
the old the old body trick go meet your
family i've just killed you now during
the scene leto lures the baron in close
and he ends up biting on the tooth which
kills everyone in the room except for
the baron using his levitation
technology the baron is able to narrowly
survive the gas and he hands over
control of the planet to his nephew
rabban played by dave batista spice
production starts again once more and we
see as paul and jessica reunite with one
of the house's most trusted fighters
duncan idaho alongside him is dr lee
kynes who is a person that has
allegiances to both the fremen and also
the imperium after reaching an old
research station they were attacked by
the suduka
not sudoku who were hired by the baron
to help out in the coup as prophesized
duncan ends up dying and lyek kind
sacrifices herself by luring a sand worm
to their location this leaves just paul
and jessica who come face to face with
the fremen and paul realizes he's
finally met the woman of his dreams now
the fremen are of course the natives of
the planet and due to living in the
desert they value moisture very highly
this is why upon greeting the atreides
earlier in the movie the leader still
got spits at them cena's weak amongst
his people a fighter named jamis wants
to challenge paul and jessica in order
to impress his peers this leads to a
final fight between he and paul in which
the latter easily wins paul doesn't want
to kill him but according to freman law
it must be a fight to the death and thus
paul ends up killing the character he
and his mother stay on arrakis and they
end up joining with the fremen in order
to tear down the oppressors of the
planet and free the people we see that
they have truly mastered the environment
and all its creatures as we watch a
fremen riding on the back of a sand worm
we're told this is only the beginning
and realize they now have an army in
which to fight the harkinin and whoever
else should arrive now paul does end up
becoming the muadeeb which is a name
that the fremen call a desert mouse
throughout the film the character comes
across these at several points and it
further hints towards his abilities now
going beyond the movie part 2 will very
much follow him becoming integrated with
a fremen and we will learn more about
the selective breeding that created him
paul slowly starts to build his powers
amongst their community and we also
learn that jessica is actually the
baron's daughter this was kept from her
and it's quite a big gut punch that
lucas definitely didn't take we're just
playing now jessica well am i now
jessica ends up on we're not we're not
playing no no no jessica ends up
undergoing a ritual in order to become a
reverend mother that involves drinking
the poisonous water of life due to her
pregnancy the baby is also given powers
in the womb and speaking of babies paul
has a son with channy called letto ii
jessica's child is called alia and she
becomes quite important later on gurney
also reunites with them and we learn
that he's become a smuggler on the
planet in the desert paul's powers grow
and grow and he's eventually classed as
the messiah this news of a leader in the
desert reaches the baron and he starts
to instruct his house to oppress the
people even further this is a sort of
strategic play as well as he wants robin
to be so bad that when he appoints the
next person to take over they don't seem
as evil even though they suck as well as
mentioned in the movie the emperor is
very jealous and he sends spies to
arrakis to monitor it which puts strain
on the relationship that he has with the
house now gurney believes that jessica
is a traitor and he almost kills her but
paul stops this knowing that he didn't
foresee this attack he too decides to
drink the water of life as it will
increase his powers however being a man
trying to tap into the power source of
an all-female religion it doesn't prove
to be the smartest choice and he ends up
passing out after it paul is conked out
for a while but when he awakens he
finally has the ability to see across
time and space and he's now become the
quiz that's had a rach with his new
abilities he learns of the emperor and
baron's plans and he uses this knowledge
to launch a freman rebellion against the
hawkening during this aliyah is captured
and paul and the freeman ambush all of
the strongholds whilst they ride on the
back of sand worms alia ends up killing
the baron and the fremen defeat the
hawkening which brings paul face to face
with the emperor he tells him that he
must abdicate the throne otherwise he'll
destroy the spice mining facilities on
the planet ball beats the emperor's
champion and the m promises him his
daughter's hand in marriage which is a
plot point that's hinted at in the movie
paul takes the throne but it is
bittersweet as he realizes that the
fremen are now too powerful to stop now
that's pretty much the story that i
think will be covered in the sequel but
i'm a bit unsure whether we'll actually
get one and that's because i have no
idea how this movie is gonna perform not
only is it dropping on hbo max alongside
his theatrical release but the movie was
actually leaked earlier in the week add
to that the pandemic i think it's gonna
have a bit of an uphill battle in terms
of turning a profit now i did hit before
about not really jelling with the movie
that much but before discussing my
criticisms i want to talk about the
positives of the film first i'm not
someone who really likes to come in and
just slam movies and there are a lot of
things that the movie does well now
firstly the cinematography is absolutely
incredible and then he does a great job
of bringing the book to life there's a
lot of world building going on here and
some amazing shots that look like they
were ripped right out of a painting all
of the performances are incredible too
there's not really an actor here that
doesn't feel like they're not doing the
best with the material that they have
the movie has an atmosphere to it and
the attack scenes and environments all
feel very authentic leading to a great
looking film i also absolutely loved the
first hour and it completely hooked me
in and left me thinking that this was
going to be the masterpiece that i'd
been told it was however after that
first hour i think the pacing really
really suffered we kind of build up the
part in which the hawkins attack and
then from there the movie gets a lot
smaller in scale has some needless
wandering about and it doesn't really
recapture the pacer energy that it had
earlier on even the last person that
paul fights feels like a major step down
in terms of action as it's someone he
easily beats and it's not really a
character that feels like they should
have been the final battle in a movie
looking at the way they've adapted the
source material i think they've really
gone about it the wrong way and the
movie structure makes it feel like it
has a beginning middle and an end and
then a beginning in the middle following
on from it i'm gonna say something super
controversial here so hold on to your
butts but i actually think that a new
hope did a better job of adapting june
than june did now what i mean by that is
that a new hope introduces its
characters the threat we spend some time
on a planet face peril on the death star
and then have a big blowout against the
seemingly unbeatable enemy which wraps
up the movie juxtaposing this dune
introduces the characters the threat we
spend some time on a planet move there
lots of people die we stay there and
then it just kind of wind down introduce
new characters in the last 15 minutes
and then we end the movie it's a weird
way to tell the story and i think that
it does massively affect the pacing of
the film and in the end it just makes it
feel a bit bloated i was actually saying
to my friends i think it would have
worked better if they'd spent longer at
the front part of the movie and then
ended after the attack on the planet
with leno's death being what closed
things out books also don't have to be
adapted completely to remain faithful
either and i think that the movie could
have ended with paul and jessica meeting
the fremen robin showing up to get
revenge for his uncle and the final
showdown of the film being between the
fremen paul and rabban's forces this
would allow a big bad who's been laced
throughout the movie to make an impact
and it would also show the fremen that
paul wasn't messing around a new hope
kept the pace up by having us jump from
location to location from planet to
planet but here we're stuck in the sand
and though i know that's what happens in
the book it feels a bit stagnant
honestly it's kind of bloated and
there's also no real payoff knowing that
we are getting a sequel means that we
can kind of push these criticisms to the
side and be like well we will get
resolution but if warner brothers pull
the plug then i don't know if this movie
will feel like a smart move to lay this
story out the way that it did i'm not
going to score this film because hey i'm
a guy who gives something like halloween
kills a 10 out of 10 because i had fun
watching it objectively this is a better
movie than that but it's also just got a
feeling that it's not finished and thus
it's difficult to really rate it the
sequel might release and it could make
this movie much much better on
re-watches but on its own two feet i
don't feel like it's that strong that
being said it's expertly directed and i
think the best term for it is that it's
an epic space opera as a piece of art it
works incredibly well but as a movie
going experience i'm really mixed on it
i'm gonna rewatch it and obviously
people will take different things from
it and i'm hoping that down the line
that i appreciate the movie more if you
loved it then i'm glad that you enjoyed
it and if you disliked it then your
opinion is just as valid too obviously
let me know your thoughts below and if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our halloween
kills breakdown so you can see why it's
the best movie of all time if not then
thanks for sitting until the end of the
video i've been paul you've been the
best and i'll see you on the next one
take care peace